hey everyone excited to be here and you
know giving a bit about what's happening
in the world with AI regulation and you
know how we are seeing the war moving
towards a more regulated more compliant
environment
um you know give a brief intro but I
also run a AI Venture Studio out of
Austin and Saints is one of the
companies we built we are working on a
lot of other companies so I've been in
this space for quite a bit
um with that I'll kind of continue
forward with the presentation
so the way we look at it is we'll break
down blueprint of us this uh AI Bill of
Rights and its implications and this is
a less developed model as compared to
the EU AI Bill of Rights or use AI act
where they actually go a bit more and
talk about prescriptive ways to solve
problems and how we're going to tackle
them so we look at some of the ways that
they have highlighted in terms of how we
can go towards more you know comply and
start working towards AI that can be
easily understandable and trackable and
so forth
and then we'll talk a bit more about
kind of how companies are doing it
so the evolution of air regulations has
been the past couple of years use came
out kind of last year and you know just
late last year I think in September is
when
um you know us released the AI Bill of
Rights China did it even before EU and
Canada has been doing it and you know we
just see this picking up a lot more
considering the events that have been
occurring in the last couple of months
uh you know we do feel that usually
regulation is always a lot slower in
terms of catching up with Technologies
and at the scale that we are moving it's
kind of real imperative that regulation
can catch up especially for areas that
are really impactful to people
um so looking under the blueprint for
Us's AI Bill of Rights there are five
key areas that they're trying to
get AI to comply with so breaking it
into them ensuring safe and effective
systems so what this is saying is that
we're going to build systems that are
understandable we do risk mitigation
before we launch them and once we launch
it we have a way to monitor them and
ensure that they can be safe and
effective over time
second around maintaining data privacy
so the goal here is to ensure that we
can have
models that preserve or have an option
for users to have an agency or the data
that has been collected a bit similar to
how we did with gdpr and equivalent for
California around data privacy have a
reasonable effort to make sure that
there is a expectation of data privacy
cement having providing algorithmic
discrimination protections so again this
is kind of covering the
core fundamental rights of the citizens
and how we can prevent algorithmic
discrimination for them
ensuring human
Alternatives consideration and fallbacks
so where we are coming here is to
provide a way to have an even
alternative to making decisions wherever
possible so this could be something like
you know credit decisions where if you
would like to have an alternative human
to look at it then having or providing
an option for an end user to have that
last providing a notice and explanation
so
surfacing a way for humans to know that
this decision or you know this image or
this graphic or whatever was generated
using Ai and then providing an
explanation so out of leading to why
this decision was made so people are not
kind of left in the dark when they see
decisions in terms of why we got to that
decision in the first place in providing
this transparency
again this is what they say it's really
hard to take it this into practice
because there's also AI assisted
decisions completely AI oriented
decisions and how they can be providing
notice and explanation is kind of a
black box and kind of we are still in
the early days in terms of how this is
going to move towards actual
implementation
the Bill of Rights itself is non-binding
and it's not enforcing any organization
to actually act upon it so while it does
say oh we have a new Bill of Rights it's
not really being enforced anywhere today
so the next Tab and this is what
you know Council of Chambers has been
pushing for is to actually move this and
have it
start enforcing on organizations but on
the other hand we are kind of debating
between how this stifles Innovation and
how we can safely move towards a more
Progressive step
um and kind of this is this is what I
was saying the last few months this is
becoming even more evident right with
the accessibility that we're now seeing
with generative Ai and not just AI
researches but Everyday People now have
the possibility of creating generated
images right uh
I think I saw seeing an image of Pope
wearing like a big hoodie at a puffer
the other day and you know these were
fake images but it's really hard to tell
and now people are making these I think
yesterday there's an image with Elon
Musk dating uh the CEO of GM
right like at the first glance it looks
oh wow you know he found someone new but
uh it's kind of you gotta take a step
back and see and you know I saw like
Twitter started enforcing thing oh this
is like an edge on an image but a human
had to step in and do it but we don't
know how many people got exposed to this
image before they're actually able to
step in and kind of you know put a
notice that this was an AI generated
content and give the context but this is
because the tweet itself got really
popular but in a lot of use cases where
okay maybe it's exposed to 10 000 people
right we may not have someone coming in
and looking at it and flagging it so
overall how do we shift responsibility
for these things to people that are
Distributing it it's another area that
you know people are pushing for and to
ensure that this can be
more trackable
let's give that slide
um again right there were ethical
concerns right when Delhi came around
they do relaunch or due to issues with
gender and racial bias uh this is a
really popular case of I believe
Microsoft using an automated resume
screening tool a few years ago where if
we look if they were hiring for
engineering and if they could identify
this was a female then they
automatically ranked it lower in terms
of evaluation so this was kind of they
did it for a few months before they kind
of kind of came in and be like okay wait
we need to fix this end you know this
was a propagation of human bias to a
certain extent but then when you don't
have that layer and you start taking
this technology and scaling it to a lot
more people right through a large
audience those just get you know
Amplified exponentially so kind of how
do we take a step in and understand what
biases are occurring and how do we fix
them prevent them and have a way of
actually knowing in the first place what
are they
um
all right so again with the AI Bill of
Rights there are three key areas that
they're trying to protect for a is civil
rights civil liberties and privacy so
freedom of Rights sorry freedom of
speech voting protection from
discrimination and so forth making sure
these can be attained secondly around
equal opportunities so ensuring that
this Equitable access to education
housing credit employment and other
programs I don't know if you remember
with an apple cart first came out with
Goldman Sachs they had this thing where
they were not fair in the decision
making and they got blasted in the news
outlets quite a bit for this and then I
think they retractable event then fix
them and gave credit to people that
deserved it and so forth uh so being
able to ensure that AI can be used in in
a Equitable way the last allowing to
access to critical resources or services
so this is you know the basic needs
Healthcare financial services and so
forth so I think the way we are seeing
AI regulation moving and this is where
the EU has done a lot more work is to
move and identify areas that are high
impact medium impact and low impact and
start regulating in in that order as
opposed to having a blanket regulation
towards all Technologies because that's
going to stifle Innovation and slow down
progress but if we can move towards kind
of a pyramid where we go and identify
the most impactful AI areas and start
regulating those forests it would move
to a kind of easier solution uh you know
again you have some great ideas so I
know I talk about them but they also
have a concept of sandboxing and
providing that to developers to work and
launch new AI products and work with the
government to identify and regulate it
is to kind of scale it out so instead of
just not having a way to launch
something and go through all the
regulatory
Loops they have a Sandbox where they can
have or provide the access of the AI
product to a limited population with
kind of the government in the loop and
then fixed it identified regulated and
then scale it forward
um again I think these are some key
challenges in terms of opacity for ML
models these are more traditional models
we can also touch on Foundation models
and how the challenges with them differ
obviously there are a lot more
challenges they tend to be a bit subtle
and a bit different but maybe we will
first go through the challenges for
traditional ml models so
we're looking at
garbage in model bias drifts and
traceability uh not saying this is a
comprehensive list but these are some of
the areas that we have seen to be
pretty effective in kind of the first
step towards working on MN models takes
me more consistent
so kind of data coming in is what data
goes out right traditional models where
they are kind of uh specialized and
being built for one studying task the
data set has a direct impact on the last
proportion toward biasis or you know how
the data moves so if we model straight
on a certain type of data and then the
new either the training data or the new
data that we are receiving starts being
different that can lead to your outcomes
being different and this is how a lot of
adversial attacks happen so I think in
when Tesla self-driving was kind of in
order so not just Tesla for the matter
any self-driving cars people could Trek
and have certain signs on the road which
would cause the car to panic and you
know accelerate or break and so forth so
these are kind of the areas where you
can have a data being very different and
have exp like a unexpected outcome to
what the data input is
and kind of sampling error is again
another era that we see a lot of
Institutions making errors and this is
something that is kind of readily
soluble this is kind of a practical way
of looking at it so
the data that we are using to train a
model needs to be sampled correctly to
the data that's actually going to be
used in the production environment so
you know if the distribution of your
data is going to be you know 10 20 30
across you know different cities right
then you want to ensure that your
sampling can be similar
and then the other thing is about having
Upstream uh software errors a lot of
times you can have
dependencies on other software pieces
data pipelines where if there is any
kind of change on that front that can
lead to outcomes that are very different
for your models
other way we can look at is model bias
and how that carries forward to the end
outcomes
again sampling bias is saying there's
labeling bias that gets for put forth
because who are the people that actually
training the systems in the first place
and what biases that they bring the
table that get carried forward to the
end systems
then obviously like algorithm back human
bias and what this leads to is a lot of
loss of customer trust
um you know negative publicity right
where we saw a lot of these news
articles about
um
companies trying to go back
retroactively and fix these systems and
you know in the future probably some
kind of monetary compensations that
organizations will have to do for biased
models
the other big thing is models are prone
to drift
right and I'll spend a bit of time here
is the distribution of data shifts over
time right A lot of people uh treat
machine learning models as
similar to software systems right if we
build a web app or a phone app and we
launch it and as long as you know Amazon
launching a new thing and breaking your
app they kind of keep working right out
from that you had on day one when you
launched it is the outcome that you have
you know day hundred day one thousand
day two thousand right as long as
there's no other changes being made
models behave differently where models
are not the same where they drift over
time and this occurs due to a lot of
reasons right this occurs when your
behavior of users change so we look at
data Rift Concepts so concept drift is
when the actual underlying assumptions
and
assumptions on how your model is using
the data changes so the great example
that you know we always use is around
Kobe and how people's buying patterns
changed and instacart was behaving
people to expect a lot differently then
they started doing code because suddenly
you you had a Monumental shift to people
ordering online as opposed to going in
and buying groceries in person and this
led to their AI models predicting
inventory and delivery times to be
completely flipped
and the other the other issue with
machine learning models is that it's not
like a web app where you get a 404 error
right so something's wrong you got to
fix it these things are really gradual
and you modest degrade over time so you
wouldn't see the impact but maybe it's
one quarter from now two quarters from
now and you actually see customers
complaining or we have
you know quarterly Financial results and
we see that this is no longer the way
that our models are supposed to be
working people can go back and fix it
but it's a gradual decline right where
either led to loss of Revenue loss of
customers or one of the other outcomes
what you need to be doing is to
track this model drift over time as it
occurs so instead of having a peak
that's been declining for a while and
then fix it and have a big peak and then
decline again we can have a way so that
the models can be kind of fixed over
time as and adapt to the changing
scenarios
that's what concept is data Rifts again
is very important because a lot of times
the models that we are building we don't
have the ground Roots available and that
does not mean that models cannot be
tracked in terms of their performance we
can still look at either input features
and how their distributions are being
changed and the outcome and how the
distribution for that is being changed
right so if I have a model that
is predicting who to give credits to
like credit as in give a loan to or not
then we can identify the distribution of
that model and identify if that's
changing so today if I'm giving loans to
you know 35 that are applying to my loan
program versus tomorrow I suddenly see
that you know 55 percent are being
approved then that indicates that
there's some kind of potential drift in
terms of the data that's coming out of
it and that this may be flat for a human
to look at and review further
I think this talks about an example
about spam emails that were trained in
2020 for IBM and you know changed in
2022 as like spammers also learned how
to trick the systems and not use the
same techniques so having a way to
understand the drifts and adapt to that
is something that's quite important
and organizations not having
traceability in terms of what the models
were trained on when they were trained
explaining them and so forth so having a
system in place for organizations uh
however they do it either they have
existing tools to use some you know set
of docs but having this traceability in
terms of logging when the model is
released who worked on it what data was
used what expectations were there and
what is happening so that when an error
occurs and we're trying to fix it we can
go back in time look at it and fix those
items that cause those issues in the
first place
other other area it's kind of not in the
slides but to look at is monitoring your
models on
a cohort of data so oftentimes you can
be monitoring your model for let's say
all of us right it's uh
predictive model for again credit
decision so to give loans and who not to
give loans and it's for all of the US
then you know it may be looking good for
everyone on the whole maybe it's a 90
accuracy good but it's possible that for
one part one particular cohort of data
for let's say just the City of Austin or
you know ages 18 to 24. your model could
be behaving very differently but when
it's monitored as an aggregate those
valued guys averaged out and we don't
see
what it could be for that particular
cohort of data so breaking down
monitoring and understanding your models
is important not just on a global level
but also on a cohort by cohort level uh
and then that's something where our team
has done a lot of work in automatically
identifying what cohorts kind of are
less performant as compared to before
and kind of flagging them and you know
prompting monitoring for those cohorts
framework for assessing AI risk uh kind
of four areas I can derived a bit from
the eu's AI react AI Act is outlining
the goals and objectives for responsible
AI measuring and comparing so doing a
lot of work uh before the models are
launched in terms of risk mitigation
understanding where they fail what the
limitations are across different user
segments then optimizing these models
and establishing fairness
fairness is currently being done in just
confined areas like credit but a lot of
areas where fan is good and should be
done are not being done today the lastly
having a system where we can monitor and
build explainable systems and kind of
taking a step further from this and
having a way to have a human step in and
override the systems whether that means
rolling back to a previous version or
moving it to a human based uh
operations of the system so either of
those two is kind of how we can move
towards framework
some strategies to stay on par with
evolving air regulations and while every
country is starting to have their own
set of uh different air regulations I
was looking today UK is trying to do
their own thing where oh we're gonna not
have one central body to monitor but
we're going to break it down by
different impacts of it for a certain
category or certain type of Regulation
this body is going to do it if someone
else they're going to do this so but on
the whole they're still working on a
similar core set of beliefs in terms of
how AI should be regulated so this
should be fairly applicable for them
so we look at these data governance
interpretability human oversight
provision of information robustness and
documentation
so in terms of data governance I think
we I spoke a bit about it is to
understand and log the model inputs and
outputs so that we have traceability to
go back and look at it
ensuring models are running correctly
without ground truths so this is being
done with logging as well as doing data
Rift monitoring
detecting and flagging specs data
segments with the performance
dips below threshold levels so it's
creating systems that are flying these
outcomes as they occur to users and kind
of having some kind of real-time
alerting for violations depending on the
impact of the models for some of them
it's really impactful to have real time
we also work with organizations where
they run their models on a batch basis
where it's happening once a month or you
know once every two weeks where they
don't run it on a real-time basis so
it's really about how organizations are
implementing the data uh in ml practices
uh leading towards Ai explainability and
I think the most important area here is
to
not
identify which is the best technique to
do AI explainability because we see the
slimes the share this integrated
gradients and so forth a lot of new
Technologies coming out but the core
issue that we see happening is
accessibility to people who need to
understand and have access to this
information at the right time so whether
that's in business analyst that needs to
understand why this uh model predicted
an outcome in a certain way or whether
that's an AI engineer who's fixing their
models right making this information
available to them easily and at the
right time is more important so how can
organizations create systems that make
this information accessible to them both
on a global level as well as on a local
level so on a prediction by prediction
basis as well as on a global cohort
basis so
kind of analysis that are helpful are
understanding
AI explainability on
by silver last two weeks versus this
week and how has my model changed in
terms of understanding the information
and making predictions right you can
also do it on a cohort basis where you
want to understand how my model is
behaving for ages 18 to 24 versus 24 to
30 and then drawing comparations between
the two of them because it's possible
that there are hidden
inaccuracies in your models that you
don't realize until they actually start
being put out in the real world so a
good example I like to show is
if you have an image classification
model between dogs and cats right you
want to be looking at the features of
the body to identify if it's a dog or
cat right do they have what kind of skin
do they have right what's the shape of
their body so forth but it's possible
that if in all of the cad images there
was like a Christmas tree behind and all
the documents if we didn't have a
Christmas tree any model was just using
that to identify and flag it and it may
look good on the training data but when
it's around in the production
environment it may not be working the
same way so if you have and if AI
explainability we can double check the
assumptions that were used to build
these models in the first place
maintaining human oversight so I think
you know we believe that this is going
to move
across the different air regulations
with organizations implementing it so
having a way to stop operations of an
overseer
detects risk I feel like uh so this is
the same words from the eu's AI act but
I think this is derived from more like
Terminator and just someone going broke
but having a way to have a human come in
and override systems is going to be
important
monitoring for anomalies and having this
continuous monitoring to make sure that
the models are working as expected a lot
of organizations even do automated
retrainings where humans are kind of
completely away from it where new data
is coming in they're retraining the
model and deploying it again how can
they be confident that the new model
versions being deployed are going to be
consistent with their original
expectations and lastly around no having
explainability so the humans in the
picture can identify and step in as
needed
uh I can skip the slide so maintaining
security and compliance again
this will go very different based on how
AI regulation uh evolves again what I
said earlier today's AI rights are Bill
of Rights is all non-binding not asking
anyone to enforce it just being out
there as calmness evolved but as we move
towards more uh regulated environment
one of the key areas is going to be the
logging and understanding how
the data was moving and who it impacts
and who it doesn't impact so having that
traceability is going to be extremely
important
goes back to the documentation reporting
activities so
for EU they want people to have experts
within each organization that are going
to be reportable to the government when
it comes to AI regulation second thing
is having an automated logging
capabilities and lastly for them is to
where we just stay on top of model
Health reports
this is going to be important for
the entire business team now as we move
towards organization where AI is not
limited to one function but rather the
entire organization into facing it in
some way or the other
creating this automated model Health
reports and providing it to the
stakeholders is going to be a crucial
we used to look at is an Executives want
to see how the AI is impacting their n
Roi right a person that's going to be
interfacing with the customer they need
to know why a model made a certain
decision so that if a customer has a
question or they have concerns they can
be addressed and they're not an AI
engineer level we want to be able to
have this monitoring so that and
explainability so that we can understand
and go back and improve our models for
better outcomes
uh it's a wrap uh just some few things
right so from logging documenting
reporting performance analysis
monitoring them root cause analysis
being able to go very quickly and
identifying what went wrong and how we
can fix it having explainability for
them and then troubleshooting and
debugging how can we create systems that
are easy to understand and not a black
box once you've deployed because it
surprised in a lot of organizations will
deploy these great machine learning
models to their production systems but
then have no way of understanding what
is happening or have no traceability on
that front
uh just a quick one slide about us so
we've been building a single platform
from delivering Enterprise level
observability at scale so for us that
includes everything from training models
and
so we don't train models but for us it's
monitoring so
identifying and logging or training and
test data sets to validating ingesting
that performance when you deployed
recording your traffic and metadata in
terms of how your models are working the
real world and moving to monitoring so
this is performance drifts outliers
fairness automated cohort detection so
forth being able to run a b tests across
your different models as we move and
deploy them
analyzing it so having a bi like tool
for Enterprises to understand and slice
and nice different predictions and make
analysis and finally connect this back
to your trading pipelines to
Monitor and improve your systems
uh but yeah that's about us thank you
[Music]